il a voulu être l'un des premiers à se
faire vacciner alors que des essais
cliniques sont annoncés un cas d'effets
indésirables de nature allergiques
la france semble avoir accumulé un
retard colossal
une dizaine de vaccins devraient arriver
sur le marché
voilà ça y est le vaccin a été autorisée
la campagne de vaccination a commencé un
peu par tout genre par exemple en france
c'est un peu ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui est le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que les gens sont pas hyper
chaud en décembre il y avait à peu près
50 % des françaises et des français qui
comptaient se faire vacciner en janvier
sa abaissé à à peu près 40 42 % ont dans
le même temps c'était pas hyper grave
parce que de toute façon on était bon
dernier du nom de vacciner dans le monde
depuis a priori le chiffre réaugmente un
petit peu bref les sondages ça reste des
sondages mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
il ya des réticences
il ya des questions il ya des
interrogations il ya des inquiétudes du
coup il ya quelques temps je vous avais
demandé de m'envoyer par mail par
message que sais-je
les questions que vous vous posez sur
les vaccins autant vous dire que j'ai
reçu un tombereau de questions depuis
j'ai fait le tri est aujourd'hui là il
est venu le moment de vous répondre
avant de commencer je voudrais être
hyper clair sur deux points
d'abord je trouve ça complètement
légitime de se poser des questions sur
ce vaccin
moi même je me pose des questions je
m'en suis posée est plein on regarde la
lie à 0 jugement je trouve que c'est
plutôt sain en fait de se poser des
questions sur sa santé avant d'accepter
ce genre de ce genre de traitement
et deuxièmement je vais pas chercher à
vous convaincre de vous faire vacciner
nous de ne pas vous faire vacciner
je vais vous donner les infos que j'ai à
ma disposition que j'ai recherché pour
répondre à vos questions et pour que
vous puissiez prendre vous même la
décision qui vous concerne
pour faire ça donc j'ai pris vos
questions j'ai noté les plus pertinentes
et où les plus fréquentes
j'ai regardé sur les réseaux sociaux
évidemment celle qui se pose est le plus
celle que moi je me pose est celle que
mon entourage se posait ses trajets fait
un gros tri gt reclasser les unes avec
les autres en fonction des thématiques
et puis bah j'ai fait des recherches
dans les publications accessible en
ligne
j'ai interrogé j'ai fait des entretiens
téléphoniques avec des experts je
voudrais toutes les références dans la
description de la vidéo et je remercie
aussi énormément
tania louis qui m'a aidé à la re lecture
notamment de cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
aller voir son compte twitter et sa
chaîne youtube qui sont des mines d'or
de d'information sur le virus le vaccin
est aussi sur plein d'autres choses
je vous met encore une fois tous les
liens dans la dans la description et
vous pouvez aussi acheter son livre qui
est là pour le coup est totalement
d'actualité et qui s'appelle la folle
histoire des virus voilà tout ça et
plein d'autres choses je vous le remet
dans la description si vous voulez avoir
plus de renseignements allez un petit
peu plus loin mais là tout de suite on y
va parce que on a du boulot
est ce que c'est vrai que le vaccin
modifier l'adn alors déjà il ya
plusieurs types de vaccins pour
l'instant les deux vaccins qui ont eu
l'autorisation et qui sont utilisés en
france notamment
c'est des vaccins qu'on appelle à arn
messagers et c'est principalement ceux
là qui soulève des questions pourraient
très clair là on parle des vaccins
finder et modern art et si la question
de la modification de notre adn se pose
c'est parce que des traitements des
médicaments qui modifient notre adn
ça existe c'est même déjà utilisé ça
s'appelle des thérapies géniques mes
premières infos pour être très clair
les vaccins arn messager ça ne met pas
des thérapies géniques c'est différent
le vaccin arn messager voilà comment il
fonctionne en gros on injecte des
molécules d'un arn messagers des
instructions génétiques une espèce de
code
si vous voulez que nos cellules vont
décoder et qui va leur permettre de
fabriquer une protéine particulière
la protéine est ce la protéine spike
d'une protéine qui est très spécifique
du virus du coronavirus parce que c'est
celle qui lui permet de se fixer sur nos
cellules
donc une fois que nos cellules ont
produit cette protéine notre système
immunitaire va pouvoir apprendre à la
repérer et à se défendre contre elle en
gros notre corps à apprendre à fabriquer
un tout petit bout du virus qui rend pas
malade pour pouvoir apprendre à le
repérer et à se défendre contre lui pour
le jour où le vrai virus va arriver à
notre adn
il est à l'intérieur du noyau de nos
cellules
c'est là qu'ils se trouvent et là tout
ce que je viens de vous décrire ça se
passe dans nos cellules
mais ça se passe pas dans le noyau ça se
passe à l'extérieur du noyau dont il n'y
a pas accès direct à notre adn
pour être tout à fait précis ce que je
vous dis là c'est ce qui se passe dans
l'immense majorité des cas mais on peut
pas exclure que théoriquement il y ait
un risque
un film qui est une petite modification
ponctuelle de notre génome dans une
cellule par exemple mais ce qu'il faut
savoir quand même c'est que ba1 le virus
lui-même et peut provoquer ce genre de
choses
deuxièmement ce risque potentiel on peut
pas l'écarter complètement mais ça
représente un risque
tellement rare que ces humaine
impossible de donner un chiffre
et troisièmement même si ça arrivait là
on parle d'une cellule qui de toute
façon aurait appris à fabriquer la
fameuse protéine est ce donc elles
seraient détruites par notre système
immunitaire donc n'aurait pas
d'incidence à l'auberge
comment on a pu développer un vaccin
aussi alors c'est vrai que entre le
début des recherches et l'autorisation
de la commercialisation d'un vaccin
classiquement on a tendance à dire qu'il
faut une dizaine d'années là c'est
arrivé en toute petite année donc c'est
assez logique de se poser des questions
comment c'est possible d'aller aussi
vite est bas globalement il ya six
raisons à sa première raison ce virus on
le connaissait déjà très très bien parce
qu'on connaissait déjà les autres
coronavirus et notamment le sar skov
sarce comme un qui vous voulez auxquels
ils ressemblent beaucoup et sur lesquels
les chercheurs s'étaient déjà énormément
pencher pendant l'épidémie de 2003 pour
essayer de mettre au point un vaccin
par exemple il savait déjà qu'il fallait
cibler la fameuse protéine est ce la
protéine spike donc les chercheurs
partait pas de zéro c'était déjà
beaucoup de temps de gagné
et puis en 2003 l'épidémie s'est arrêtée
tout seul avant que le vaccin soit au
point là ce n'était pas le cas deuxième
raison on est dans le cadre d'une
pandémie mondiale et le virus il est
très contagieux donc il circule
énormément donc c'est moche à dire mais
c'est plus facile pour faire des tests
d'abord parce que c'est beaucoup plus
facile de trouver des gens à inclure
dans les phases de test puisqu'il y en a
énormément qui sont susceptibles d'être
infectés par ce virus
ensuite parce que ce genre d'études ça
s'arrête quand on a un nombre de
patients infectés défini à l'avancé
donc là non seulement c'est facile de
trouver des patients à inclure dans les
phases de recherches en plus comme le
dit virus est très contagieux on arrive
beaucoup plus rapidement à ce nombre de
patients infectés
donc les études elle s'arrête aussi plus
vite troisième raison toujours dans le
cadre d'une pandémie mondiale
du coup les chercheurs du monde entier
se sont mis à chercher en même temps
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et ça fait avancer les
choses beaucoup plus vite quatrième
raison on est donc dans le cadre d'une
pandémie qui menace l'économie mondiale
donc ce coup là trouver des financements
pour la recherche ça n'a pas été très
compliqué cinquième raison les progrès
technologiques ces dix vingt dernières
années les moyens à disposition des
chercheurs ont énormément augmenté et
juste pour regarder l'exemple du vaccin
arn messager c'est une technique qui
étaient déjà prêtes
il y avait juste à trouver une
application sixième et dernière raison
quand il ya urgence sanitaire est là
clairement c'est le cas les procédures
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché des
médicaments et des vaccins là en
l'occurrence elles sont modifiés pour
que ça aille plus vite ça on va en
parler on va en reparler tout de suite
mais est ce que le vaccin est moins
fiable parce qu'il a été autorisé en
urgence voilà je vous avais dit qu'on
allait en parler les autorisations de
mise sur le marché les 1 mm elles sont
données par l' agence européenne du
médicament et par l' agence nationale de
sécurité des médicaments et des produits
de santé
la nfl en temps normal c'est des
procédures qui sont très longues mais
comme on l'a dit on peut les accélérer
s'il ya vraiment un besoin urgent ça se
fait souvent par exemple dans le cas de
nouveaux traitements contre les cancers
si on estime que ces traitements sont
très efficaces et que ça concerne des
cas pour lesquels on n'a rien d'autre de
disponible pour l'instant
là en l'occurrence on a un virus est
très contagieux
une pandémie mondiale avec des
répercussions sur les systèmes de santé
sur la vie économique sur la vie tout
court des gens de la population du monde
entier
du coup il ya une urgence sanitaire et
ya pas de traitement il n'y a pas de
vaccin y a rien donc procédure accélérée
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
pour avoir l'autorisation
utilisé un médicament d'accent là en
l'occurrence on peut accélérer les
procédures mais il ya quelque chose
qu'on peut pas allégé c'est les critères
de fiabilité les critères de sécurité
pour avoir cette année même il faut
pouvoir prouver deux choses d'abord que
le traitement le vaccin il est efficace
donc vous prouver son efficacité
et il faut aussi prouver qu'il est sans
danger donc il faut prouver son
innocuité ensuite on fait le calcul
et on regarde si un le bénéfice qu'on va
avoir à l'utiliser
ce médicament est plus important que les
risques qui auraient à l'utiliser à
savoir essentiellement les effets
indésirables
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fameuse
balance bénéfices risques est ça qui est
urgence ou pas on n'écoute pas il faut
absolument que ces critères là soient
respectés en temps normal pour monter ce
genre de dossier il faut fournir tout un
tas d'informations de données et
d'éléments aux autorités sanitaires
ça c'est très très long et tant que le
dossier est pas considéré comme complet
on n'a pas le droit d'avancer on peut
pas passer à la phase suivante
là il faut fournir le même dossier mais
la différence c'est que on a le droit de
commencer à bosser et de compléter le
dossier au fur et à mesure que les
informations arrivent donc ça fait
gagner un temps énorme
donc en plus de tous les autres terres
qu'on a déjà vu qui font gagner du temps
là on a cette simplification
administrative si vous voulez qui permet
de faire gagner du temps mais avec les
mêmes exigences de fiabilité
est-ce qu'on a assez de recul ça je veux
pas mentir c'est une des questions qui
revient le plus souvent et je trouve ça
assez logique à bologne alors très
clairement en termes de temps passé de
10 ans à un an
oui on a moins de recul en termes de
temps par contre comme on l'a vu on a pu
inclure énormément de patients dans les
études cliniques du fait de la
contagiosité et de la circulation
mondiale du virus donc ça c'est une
forme de recul aussi le nombre de cas
étudiés un autre truc qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la majorité des effets
secondaires apparaît au bout de six à
huit semaines
donc en gros on va dire de moi ça c'est
un recul temporel qu'on a eu pendant les
essais cliniques là pour le moment dans
les phases de test ce soit pour pfizer
ou pour modern art il n'y a pas eu plus
d'événements indésirables graves dans le
groupe des personnes
ciné que dans le groupe des personnes
qui ont reçu un placebo je vais revenir
un petit peu plus tard sur cette
explication de comment ça se passe
vraiment les essais cliniques en tout
cas voilà ça chez ça il n'y a pas eu
plus d'événements indésirables graves
chez les gens qui ont reçu le vaccin que
chez les gens qui ont reçu un placebo
un événement indésirable grave c'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui est attribué
à ce compte à ce compte un gect c'est ça
peut être une appendicite
ça peut être un infarctus du myocarde ce
genre de chose qui peut arriver dans la
vie de tous les jours est donc pour le
moment blanc n'a pas eu plus chez les
vaccinés que chez les non vaccinés
il ya eu des cas de paralysie de belles
vous en avez peut-être entendu parler la
paralysie de belles c'est une faiblesse
ou une paralysie de en général la moitié
du visage
généralement ça passe tout seul ou sous
traitement mais bon évidemment c'est
flippant c'est pas agréable personne n'a
envie d'avoir ça alors on va parler
chiffres du coup la paralysie de bell
il y en a eu quatre cas sur vingt-deux
mille personnes pendant les phases de
test ça donnerait 18 cas sur cent mille
personnes et l'incidence habituel de la
maline la fréquence habituelle de la
maladie vaccination ou pas c'est 20 cas
sur cent mille personnes
donc il y en a pas eu plus avec le
vaccin que en temps normal mais au final
que ce soit pour ça ou ce qui pourrait
arriver maintenant qu'on a commencé à
vacciner à grande échelle la population
mondiale
les autorités sanitaires avons continué
à suivre ça de très près et au final le
vaccin il a été autorisé parce que la
balance bénéfice risque
elle est ok
c'est quoi les effets indésirables donc
là on parle évidemment des effets
indésirables qui ont été observés chez
les gens qui ont été vaccinés pendant
les phases de test le nombre de patients
inclus dans ces études là et leurs
caractéristiques ça fait qu' ils sont
considérés comme représentatifs de la
population générale
donc on s'attend à ce que les effets
indésirables ont été observées sur ce
panel de la population et leur
proportion ce soit la même dans la
population générale maintenant qu'on va
vacciner maintenant qu'on a commencé à
vacciner énormément de gens forcément il
ya des choses qui vont arriver qu'on
n'avait pas vue pendant les phases de
tests qui ont été menées sur plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
donc il ya des choses qui vont arriver
qu'on a pas vu pour l'instant mais
statistiquement cela va concerner très
peu de gens et du coup la balance
bénéfice risque
elle va quoiqu'il arrive le reste est ok
et donc les effets indésirables les plus
fréquents observés pendant les phases de
tests et un petit peu là maintenant
depuis le début de la vaccination c'est
les grands classiques douleur au point
d'injection fatigue maux de tête un
petit peu de température des courbatures
voir des douleurs articulaires des
troubles digestifs minimes genre nausées
diarrhées etc
le grand classique des effets
secondaires des médicaments et les
effets indésirables graves ont été
attribués aux vaccins
c'est des réactions allergiques de
modérée à sévère voire des chocs
anaphylactiques chez des gens qui
avaient déjà un terrain allergique
assez assez costaud donc tout ça ça va
continuer à être surveillé mais
globalement on va pas avoir beaucoup
plus de surprise que ce qu'on sait
marche
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ces
pourcentages d'efficacité ouais c'est
vrai que la question se pose parce que
ces chiffres ne sont pas hyper simple à
comprendre
petit rappel comme on a dit pour avoir
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
pour un traitement un vaccin
il faut qu'on prouve son innocuité c'est
à dire l'absence d'effets indésirables
graves fréquents et il faut donc qu'on
pousse ont une efficacité
alors pour comprendre ces chiffres
d'efficacité on va prendre l'exemple du
vaccin de pfizer
l'étude elle a été menée sur plusieurs
milliers sur même plusieurs dizaines de
milliers personnes
et voilà comment ça s'est passé la
moitié des volontaires a reçu le vaccin
walser l'autre moitié a reçu un placebo
de la flotte ça les petits houles et ni
les volontaires ni les médecins qui les
ont suivis pendant les phases de test
savait qu'ils avaient reçu le vaccin et
qui avait reçu un placebo
ensuite ces volontaires ils ont mené
leur vie comme si de rien n'était ils
ont juste été suit les tester
régulièrement
et puis quand on est arrivé au chiffre
de 170 personnes infectées c'était le
chiffre établi à la vente dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure on a regardé qui
étaient ses 170 personnes qui avaient
été infectés par le virus sur ses 170
personnes malades
il y en avait 100 62 c'est à dire 95%
qui avait reçu un placebo et 8
c'est à dire 5 % qui avaient reçu le
vaccin riser donc on considère que
recevoir le vaccin
ça diminue de 95 % le risque d'être
malade
c'est comme ça que ça marche est-ce
qu'on a inoculé le virus aux volontaires
pendant les tests alors c'est marrant
c'est pas une question que je mettais
posez-moi spontanément mais comme cette
question qui est revenue très très
souvent je vais vous répondre
non on n'a pas inoculé le virus à des
gens pour voir si le vaccin était
efficace on ne fait pas ça les études
elles ont été menées sur des volontaires
qui étaient exposés au virus
de par leur mode de vie et comme on a vu
le virus étant très contagieux il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont
particulièrement exposés au virus
donc on a choisi les volontaires dans
des populations dans lesquels le virus
circule particulièrement mais on leur a
pas injecter exprès je suis jeune et en
bonne santé pourquoi je me ferai
vacciner
oui je vois le raisonnement le virus
situent majoritairement des personnes
âgées ou des personnes fragiles si c'est
pas mon cas vu que j'ai des doutes
pourquoi est ce que j'irai me faire
vacciner d'abord c'est vrai qu'à moins
de risques chez les personnes jeunes et
en bonne santé mais il ya quand même eu
des cas de formes graves voire de décès
chez des personnes jeunes et en bonne
santé
donc là encore ça on revient à quels
risques vous êtes prêts à prendre
ensuite encore une fois si le vaccin
il a été autorisé c'est parce que la
balance bénéfice risque elle penche du
côté des bénéfices donc en vous faisant
vacciner
vous mettez plus de chances de votre
côté que vous ne prenez de risques ça
c'est des premiers éléments de réponse
mais à mon avis les questions qu'il faut
surtout se poser c'est si je me vaccine
est-ce que je protège aussi les autres
et est ce que je fais en sorte que
l'épidémie s'arrête plus vite ça on va
en reparler un petit peu plus tard vu
que le virus mute
est-ce que les vaccins vont continuer à
être efficace alors on a vu que l'angle
d'attaqué des vaccins c'est la protéine
spahic dans le var y en anglais par
exemple qui est déjà arrivée sur le
territoire français une partie des
mutations elle concerne justement cette
protéine spike a priori avec les
premières données qu'on a pour l'instant
ces mutations elles concernent une
partie infime de la protéine qui fait
que logiquement elle va continuer à être
reconnaissables par le système
immunitaire donc les vaccins devraient
continuer à être efficace sa demande
être consolidée mais pour l'instant
premiers éléments qu'on a c'est plutôt
rassurant pour le variant sud africain
qui est aussi présent sur le territoire
français on n'est pas encore sûr pour le
moment mais les scientifiques ne peuvent
pas être vraiment catégorique il ya
aussi des mutations sur cette protéine
est ce on sait pas dans quelle mesure ça
va remettre en question l'efficacité du
vaccin et pour le vario brésilien on
sait pas encore on n'a pas encore assez
de données bon a priori il n'est pas
arrivé en france
pas encore
peut-être même qu'au moment où vous
regardez cette vidéo ce sera le cas mais
parce qu'évidemment pour cette question
là comme pour toutes les autres
questions
ce qu'on sait depuis le début c'est que
les connaissances évoluent tellement
vite que ce qui est vrai un jour et pas
forcément vrai le lendemain mais alors
s'il y avait des variations des
mutations très importante sur cette
protéine spike au point que ça remette
en question l'efficacité des vaccins
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire eh bien
il faudrait modifier les vaccins la
bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est jouable
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que ça nous
ferait perdre un petit peu de temps sur
la vaccination donc sur la sortie de la
crise sanitaire sur la sortie de la
pandémie mais c'est jouable
on peut modifier le vaccin pour
l'adapter à une nouvelle variation autre
truc un peu gênant avec ces variants
c'est que ils sont a priori pas plus
dangereux mais ils sont plus contagieux
voire beaucoup plus contagieux et ça ça
à d'autres conséquences dont on va
reparler après est-ce que le vaccin va
permettre d'arrêter la pandémie ouais ça
c'est quand même un gros morceau c'est
quand même une grosse question c'est
peut-être même la grosse question dans
un premier temps ça va nous permettre de
faire un petit point
pourquoi est-ce qu'on vaccine les gens
contre le colis ça sert déjà à protéger
les personnes les plus à risque
celles qui vont être vaccinés en premier
c'est les personnes âgées et les
personnes qui ont des maladies
chroniques
donc ça va permettre d'éviter
directement des décès est comme ça
permet de diminuer le nombre de malades
et de formes graves notamment
ça permet aussi de préserver le système
de santé et notamment les réanimations
parce que les réanimations ça nécessite
du personnel qualifié et du matériel
spécifique notamment et que du coup elle
a beaucoup de lit et que du coup si
toutes les places de réanimation sont
prises par des malades qui ont des
formes graves
du coup vide bah ça veut dire que on a
plus de place pour soigner tous les
autres malades qui ont des formes graves
du code vide mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'on a plus de place pour soigner tous
les autres malades qui ont besoin de
réanimation genre les accidents de la
route les abc et c'est donc en
préservant le système de santé en
préservant les réanimations on sauve
aussi ses villas indirectement et on
permet aussi aux soignants de souffler
un peu parce que là pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas et ils vont pas tenir
comme ça
pendant des années mais bon la grande
question c'est est-ce que la vaccination
ça peut permettre d'arrêter de stopper
la pandémie et basse a dans un premier
temps on en n'était pas complètement sûr
à vrai dire on en n'est toujours pas
complètement sûr je vais vous expliquer
ça alors pour dire les choses simplement
ce qui a été prouvé
parce que c'est ce qui a été recherché
pendant les phases de test c'est que le
vaccin évite de tomber malade et ça a
aussi permis de démontrer que pour les
gens qui tombent quand même malade parce
qu'on a vu qu'il en avait ça évite de
développer des formes graves
donc le vaccin nous empêche de tomber
nous malades quand on est en contact
avec le virus quand on est contaminé
mais est ce que ça nous empêche pour
autant de refilé le virus aux autres ça
très clairement dans l'absolu
scientifiquement parlant on peut pas
l'affirmer il va falloir des tests
spécifiques pour pouvoir être affirmatif
à 100 % à la fin des phases de test on
avait plutôt l'impression que la réponse
était oui ça paraît même masse est
logique
ça diminue le risque de tomber malade et
ça diminue aussi le risque de
transmettre le virus
mais encore une fois ça n'a pas été
démontrée scientifiquement par contre
les premières études qui ont été menées
sur les populations vaccinées parce que
là il commence à y avoir vraiment
beaucoup de monde ça semble plutôt aller
dans ce sens là oui ça permettrait aussi
de limiter la transmission du virus donc
pour l'instant tous les indicateurs
semblent aller dans le bon sens le
vaccin pourrait permettre de limiter la
transmission donc de stopper la pandémie
mais tant qu'on n'a pas les preuves
scientifiques on va pouvoir être
affirmatif là-dessus à 100%
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour que le
vaccin permettent d'atteindre l'immunité
collective
oui alors la fameuse immunité collective
en ce qui concerne le coronavirus donc
le virus responsable du coc vide
en france on estime qu'il faudrait que
60 % environ de la population soit
immunisée pour atteindre l'immunité
collective immunisés naturellement c'est
à dire après avoir été en contact avec
le virus par exemple
avoir été malade ou d'immuniser par le
biais de la vaccination
je vais pas détailler tout ça de façon
très précise avec des chiffres mais je
vous mets dans la description une vidéo
faite par les abbés l'eau pour le monde
qui explique tout ça de façon très
claire et très précise mais en gros
entre les personnes qui choppe locaux
vides et qui vont développer des
anticorps et les personnes qui se font
vacciner
il faudrait qu'il y ait six personnes
sur dix qu'ils soient immunisés en même
temps contre le coc vide pour que
l'épidémie s'arrête en france alors ça
c'est dans l'absolu sauf que au bout du
compte il ya quand même une ou deux
questions qui se posent par rapport à ça
d'abord il ya la durée de l'immunité
on a une notion que les anticorps
diminuent voire disparaissent dans le
sang des personnes qui ont été malades
dont qui ont été immunisés au bout de
quelques mois alors attention ça ça veut
pas dire que ces personnes arrêtent
d'être immunisé c'est pas parce qu'il ya
plus d'anticorps dans leur sens qu'elles
sont plus immunisés gars les cellules
mémoires qui peuvent par exemple
relancer le processus
en cas de nouvelle exposition au virus
d'ailleurs a priori il ya eu très peu de
cas de réinfection et du coup bas pour
le vaccin la question se pose de la même
façon sauf que là on vaccine pas depuis
assez longtemps pour savoir combien de
temps l'immunité dur dans sa cavale à
titre de comparaison l'immunité contre
la grippe saisonnière
après une vaccination elle dure six à
neuf mois pour le coc vide va falloir un
petit peu attendre pour un an des
chiffres encore une fois mais il ya de
grandes chances que ce soit aussi
variable d'un individu à l'autre
mais même en admettant que l'immunité
elles durent six suis moi comme c'est ce
qu'on suppose actuellement mais encore
une fois il n'y a pas de certitude
on peut espérer que entre les gens qui
se fait naturellement et les gens qui
seront vaccinés on arrive à 60% de
personnes immunisées dans quelques mois
donc qu'on puisse rouvrir les
restaurants les bars les salles de
concerts les festivals tout ça mais
autre petit truc pour pondérer un peul
enthousiasme le rsa déjà estimé qu'il ya
très peu de chances que au niveau
mondial on arrive à l'immunité
collective en 2021
parce que on est pas tous au même niveau
en termes de vaccination et c'est donc
l'effort il va être mondial mais pays
par pays
quand même il ya possibilité qu on y
arrive et puis de toute façon même sans
arriver à ce fameux niveau d'immunité
collective puis il ya des gens qui me
disaient moins il ya de malades - il ya
deux formes graves - les hôpitaux sont
surchargés donc c'est déjà un bénéfice
par contre dernier élément qui pourrait
pour le coup un peu changé la donne
les fameux nouveaux variants dont on a
dont on a parlé même en admettant que
les vaccins restent efficaces sur les
variants ça pose un autre problème parce
que comme on l'a vu ces variants qu'ils
sont plus contagieux voire beaucoup plus
contagieux que la forme initiale du
virus
et ça ça pose un problème parce que si
ces variants il devenait majoritaire sur
le territoire français ça modifierait la
formule qui permet de calculer le
pourcentage de population immunisé à
atteindre pour avoir l'immunité
collective
en gros plus que ces variants sont plus
contagieux ça ferait augmenter le faire
f0 et du coup ça ferait augmenter le
pourcentage de la population immunisé à
atteindre pour avoir l'immunité
collective
donc là encore une fois on saura ça dans
les mois qui viennent au bout de combien
de temps est-ce que le vaccin est
efficace alors pas tout de suite
enfin pas immédiatement pour le vaccin
de pfizer par exemple les études elles
ont montré que l'efficacité maximale
elle arrive une semaine après la
deuxième injection parce qu'il faut deux
injections
donc logiquement au bout d'un mois
puisqu'il faut trois semaines minimum
entre la première et la deuxième
injection
sauf que comme pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore beaucoup de doses de vaccin parce
que c'est pas encore produit en masse et
grande quantité le gouvernement a décidé
d'allonger le temps entre la première et
la deuxième injection pour qu'ils aient
plus de gens qui puissent bénéficier de
la première injection
dans l'absolu c'est pas idiot sauf que
ça pose quand même deux questions
d'abord ça va allonger le délai pour
arriver à l'efficacité maximale du
vaccin ils ont parlé de passer de trois
à six semaines entre les deux injections
dans l'absolu c'est ok monsieur oms
lundi c'est souhaitable de faire ça dans
les trois à quatre semaines
mais en cas de circonstances
exceptionnelles on peut leur poussée
jusqu'à six semaines
sauf que ça veut quand même dire que le
vaccin au lieu d'être efficace au bout
d'un mois il efficace au bout de sept
semaines
on n'est pas le seul pays d'un
gouvernement a choisi cette stratégie là
mais il ya quand même des médecins qui
met en garde qui disent que ça pourrait
avoir des conséquences
il ya donc certains médecins qui disent
que ça pourrait avoir des conséquences
sur l'efficacité du vaccin
au final voir sur la capacité du virus à
muter voir que ce serait même
potentiellement embêtant d'être en
contact avec le virus dans cette période
entre les deux injections ça pourrait un
petit peu aggravé les choses
pour l'instant c'est juste des
hypothèses mais ça mérite de garder ça
en tête quand même est-ce que je vais me
faire vacciner
alors c'est une question qui est revenue
très souvent dans un premier temps je
pensais pas forcément y répondre parce
que dans mon esprit c'est pas le sujet
l'idée c'est pas savoir ce que moi je
vais faire l'idée c'est de vous donner
les infos que j'ai récupéré pour que
vous fassiez votre votre idée vous mais
après je me suis posé la question dans
l'autre sens et je me suis dit est-ce
qu'il ya une raison qui devrait me
pousser à ne pas le dire déjà est-ce que
ça risque pas de donner l'impression que
je cache quelque chose où je sais pas
pas dans l'absolu c'est moi que ça
concerne c'est ma santé c'est un choix
personnel
encore une fois mais en vrai je m'en
fous quand georges pad pas de raison de
garder le secret par rapport à ça donc
je vais vous dire je vous donner la
réponse à cette question est donc la
réponse s'est vu ce que je sais de ce
virus
maintenant et de son évolution les
variants et s'est vu la répercussion que
cette pandémie là depuis presque un an
sur ma vie puisqu'il s'agit de moi sur
la vie de mes proches sur la ville de
tout le monde en fait vu ce que je sais
maintenant sur les vaccins puisque c'est
quand même de ça qu'il s'agit
moi à titre personnel je vais me faire
vacciner dès que possible
voilà je vais me faire vacciner et je
vais me faire vacciner sans plus
d'inquiétude que j'en ai ressenti à
chaque fois que je me suis fait vacciner
ou même à chaque fois que je prends un
médicament qui a été autorisé voilà est
encore plein d'autres questions qui se
posent évidemment il y en a plein
d'autres qui vont encore se poser dans
les semaines et dans les mois qui
viennent au fur et à mesure que les
choses vont évoluer que les choses vont
avancer
je leur ferai peut-être une vidéo ici
pour pour en parler ou on en parlera
peut-être sur twitch je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas les questions c'est pas
terminé ça c'est sûr en attendant bas
vous avez quand même déjà un certain
nombre d'infos n'hésitez pas à aller
vous renseigner ailleurs avec les liens
que je vous mets
la description mais aussi par vos
propres moyens parce que c'est important
d'avoir plusieurs sources d'information
et puis de se mettre de se garder
informés avec des infos à jour puisque
encore une fois ça évolue tellement vite
que toutes ces infos elles sont
obsolètes très rapidement en attendant
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien même si c'est pas la
période idéale pour le faire et surtout
portez vous bien